forse benvenuti lo nuovissimo vita negli
ultimi giorni mi sono arrivati dei fondi
nuovi e tanti di voi ha detto sì ma
marina cioè faccio un video e di tlc
belle storie vogliamo vederli vogliamo
la review e allora ho deciso di fare
questo video dove vi farò vedere sia i
fondi miei soliti che uso che ho usato
con cui mi trovo bene sia quelli modi
che proveremo insieme vorrebbe scoprire
quali saranno bocciati e quali saranno
promossi venite nulla allora iniziamo
subito e vi farei subito notare quanto è
sobria la mia fa prove di trucco io
trovo top devo veramente partito ok ok
ok ok
prima di tutto metterei il mio
fantastico meraviglioso io unico senza
di far italy se scendesse magari facendo
scendesse sarebbe anche nei nei video
miei figli
instagram make up artist devono cadere
litri di broughton ragazzi si risparmia
ripassa solo un pump mi sono documentato
ho scoperto che quando spiace sia il
fondotinta che insomma insieme cedesse
dice tante io non lo dirò perché non mi
piace quindi io dirò premuda che siamo
tutti d'accordo univers mandela partiamo
da all nighter di urban decay primo
amore l'ho usato
per 23 anni fino all anno scorso inverno
e vi racconto questa storia allora io
usavo il 3.5 poi mi vedete no io sono di
arzana bianca fantasma ecco del 3.5
effettivamente abbastanza oscurino io
non lo so perché avevo comprato questo e
mi ci trovavo parecchio bene poi cosa è
successo l'anno scorso su instagram pure
di voi mi hanno detto marina guarda che
hai uno stanco tra gli small
effettivamente guardando era vero
ragazze io non me n'ero mai accolta
quindi vado da sephora e dico che questo
problema devo prenderlo più chiaro e
insieme analizziamo la cosa visto che io
ho fatto di trattamenti di peering
perché ho avuto un po di problemi di
acne la pelle visti è sbiancata mi si è
sbiancata perché quando usiamo quello
che so cretina quando usiamo questo era
il mio colore e sbiancando sise
schiarite non andava più bene e quindi
ho dovuto prendere addirittura dal 3.5
sono scesa al 2
allora quello che mi piace di onna iter
e che ha una coprenza tipo cerone
barbara d'urso toto cioè copre benissimo
adesso proviamo insieme come vedete è
molto molto chiaro
però si vanno abbassati al mio incarnato
si stende non proprio facilmente perché
molto molto denso come vedete superma
beh lasciamo l'occhiaia che rimane così
magari volevo anche super coprente
bianco come carlsberg ma devo dire che è
effettivamente la mia tonalità allora io
di solito non lo stendo col pennello
destro perché volevo fare la profession
amara realtà io uso il mio fantastico
beauty blend buco li trovo 300 volte
meglio
che ne dite vi piace non mi piace
passiamo a born this way di giu face che
ho comprato dopo aver utilizzato questo
qui comunque vari uso sempre tutti e due
però ultimamente sto usando di più
questo perché anche con l'estate di
mezzo volevo qualcosa silico brent ma
non eccessivamente cerone anche perché
grazie dio il problema alla belle che ho
avuto è migliorato parecchio
questo qui in particolare si chiama ai
voli sicuramente è una texture molto più
meno densa non è liquida però è
sicuramente meno calcestruzzo di con
nighter anche a livello di sensazione
lascia la pelle mi sento i pori meno
otturate rispetto a questo non so se
avete mai provato questa sensazione la
sento un po più libera di respirare
comunque questa marina
devo dire un piccolissimo problemino che
ho riscontrato usando born this way è il
fatto che soprattutto questa zona pic e
a quanto pare nella zona
la bella e più grossa perché ho la pelle
vista quindi qui diciamo che dove
diventò più lucida con born this way
diventa leggermente lucida non è lucido
grasso che dà fastidio ma il lucido che
con una passata di polvere opacizzante
va subito via allora tramadol nighter
born this way
ero andata a chiedere appunto da sephora
un un fondotinta meno in calcestruzzo
meno cerone perché più che altro per
tutti i giorni nel senso quando giro i
video di solito fuso un fondotinta ad
alta coprenza verrà compiuto avere
l'effetto di all'ato ma per tutti i
giorni mi sembrava eccessivo quindi mi
hanno consigliato questo qui di pecca è
vero marcia in più foundation
questo per shell e non lo uso da un coro
usavo prima dell'estate
siamo il pennello facciamo felice mai
trovati
[Musica]
diciamo che coprenza medio bassa
come potete vedere anche questo è
parecchio chiaro infatti poi appena ho
iniziato a prendere colore che non
ebbero usarmi ma prenderemo
noi constatiamo suo mito natura testate
mite sempre pronti a bronzi io non è che
non mi approccio io non mi voglio
abbronzare soprattutto in viso perché ho
la pelle molto delicata e voglio
prevenire le rughe quindi ragazze è
bello abbronzarsi ma mi raccomando usate
sempre la protezione e preferite la
belle curata pulita e giovane
all'abbronzatura che dura due settimane
poi va via
la pelle vi resta per sembra allora la
texture e molto setosa molto setosa
anche al tatto e sino al di là non è che
come per proprio poco e coprente ma non
da quell effetto appunto di cerone
quindi era esattamente quello che
cercavo io da usare tutti i giorni non
per i video adesso passiamo a a tutti i
fondotinta che non ho ancora provato che
mi sono arrivati proprio in questi
giorni quindi quelli che avete visto
nelle mie storie instagram non mi segui
su instagram inizio a seguirmi mi chiamo
marina ufficiali da dove iniziamo allora
innanzitutto vi faccio vedere allora mi
arrivato da puro bio sublim drop
foundation poi non si fa altro che
parlare di questo qualche stop workshop
dx mi sono arrivati anche loro in tre
tonalità e poi mi sono arrivati ben 12 e
lo ebbi di benefit
ma ne parliamo dopo inizierei a punto da
che sto qua slot di hicks fulco great
foundation quindi dovrebbe essere super
coprente tenuta 24 ore maps finissima
proprio e devo capire solo quale mi sono
arrivati i vanilla natural blight
vanilla prova villa mi ricorda poi this
way
ma questo pochi giorni a questo è un po
più per i just proviamoli tutti ii
sovente evitato tutto
dovrò pure capire qual è quello giusto
per me da utilizzare allora iniziamo con
light
sì questo evento
arte vivente
[Musica]
ok lo so ha una texture strano
proviamo con le dita proviamo vanilla
con le dita procura prossimo anno altro
dato non capiscono la coprenza mi
aspettavo di più cioè mi aspettavo una
roba alone nighter direi coerenza meglio
media intorno al naso ho capito il
rossore meno cooper diciamo a livello
compreso mi sembra simile a born this
way motore mi sono fissata con gli
adorati inodore vedi che non sono
proprie sanissima e dopo che le
professioniste per capire qual è la
tonalità giusta sera spalmano tramite il
viso e il collo perché quello è il punto
debole sole non arriva mai
quindi dove la tua pelle perfettamente
priva di colore
e proprio la tonalità ma io lo sapevo io
no neanch'io scherza get off
quindi il mio colore abbiamo trovato e
vanilla ken stott consob vanilla e light
lo userò per quando devo fare bianca né
le bris trucchi
passiamo a puro bio sublim drone
foundation di prodotti bio sono tutti
cruelty free ed io iniziare a provare il
più chiaro questi sono 04 03 proviamo 03
molto carino l'applicatore mi ricorda
quello del siero come so prima che non
usciva no la cosa bella è che la texture
è molto fluida e vi ricorda qualcosa
della mia infanzia
il pongo non pro e cuocere sei sempre
buono ed etico perché ti dà l'effetto
molto luminoso molto glowig sono molto
fiera della mia dialettica per quanto
riguarda i trucchi passerei anello happy
di benefit sono il packaging di 22 utile
sono veramente meravigliosi e super
super super lippi nel frattempo
shakerare bene software foundation
la definisce questi quindi ritirano
profuma buonissimo vi ricorda qualcosa
da allora questo come quelli di puro bio
ha una texture semi max ma molto
colloqui molto shiny devo dire che uno è
lo è più approvato un ovvio ho provato
knicks devo ancora capire ma per adesso
approviamolo in fase di approvazione
io direi che nel mio cuore permangono
born this way è online sia per coprenza
sia per fini sia per tutto questo che
non vi ho detto è più benefit non mi ha
inviato solo 1 e 2 livello happy mi ha
inviato tutte e 12 le tonalità in cui la
più scura faccia subito vedere è questa
[Musica]
ecco tanti di voi visto che le avete
viste le storie prossima marino sa cosa
te ne fai
scusate quando faccio le abitazioni le
parodie
vi ricordate aida era super abbronzate
non sono dovute a mettere più scura e ai
tempi l'avevo comprata capito adesso che
le hall e mick so come voglio e riesco
creare ben etnia questa una cosa
favolosa quindi cosa facciamo con 12
tonalità di e lo ebbi la prima cosa
viene in mente
proviamo le tutta partiamo dal mondo
numero uno proseguiamo con il 2
diciamo che non sono bravissima come
pittrice faccio un po fatica la tre poi
quattro la5 sta accadendo marina cela
cui
la5 bella prepotente la 6 la7 sarà
ancora più poi abbiamo la 8 santovetti
vabbè ragazzi e apprezzato lo sforzo nei
baci l'africa
[Musica]
mancano 15
allora nel frattempo mi sono fatto anche
un po di contouring nodo ultima nuance
la xii sono molto simili le ultime io
devo dire che a questo punto si può fare
anche qualche opera artistica 9 di
fronte perché lo faccio mai
allora purtroppo il video finisce qui
spero che questo make up schiaccia e la
situazione un po sfuggita di mano ma io
mi trovo molto molto carina variopinta e
lui mi raccomando se non vi siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi al mio canale per
non perdervi perle come questo video e
soprattutto seguitemi su tutti gli altri
social instagram facebook e tic toc su
instagram avrete modo di vedere tutti
gli ambiti nng ed utili i trucchi che mi
arriveranno in futuro e ai quali
dedicherò un altro fantastico video come
questo spero di non deludere mai le
vostre aspettative
da più di guru vivando tanti baci
stellari a tutti voi ci vediamo al
prossimo video di make up
io adoro
[Musica]